okay
it's a little bit after 1 30 central
time
so we will get started welcome everyone
and thank you for
choosing to attend our talk on
integrating common core
math standards into wolfram alpha my
name is anne-marie torrison
and i recently joined the wolfram alpha
math content team as a math education
specialist
and previously i was teaching high
school math and working on a master's
degree in
teaching secondary math and so when i
joined the wolfram alpha team this
project
the common core was already underway in
the hands of the amazing jeremy stratton
smith
thanks emory i'm jeremy stratton smith
i'm
a a math content developer for wolfram
alpha
um i've been with the company for just
under two years now
and was really excited to um to get this
project moving
um about nine months ago i think and um
i uh also have some teaching experience
before starting at wolfram i was
teaching for a year
um so it was yeah it was really great to
get into this
um so today um
we are going to be uh talking through a
little bit
um of just a background around what are
the common core state standards
for folks who might not be uh familiar
with them and then we're gonna get into
some of the details of
how these have been integrated into
wolfram alpha and
how you all as end users can access and
interact with them
and we'll wrap up with some future work
and and the continuing ongoing things
that we're
doing to flesh out or support the common
core standards
great so as jeremy mentioned starting
with
a brief overview of what the common core
state standards are
well the common core standards exist for
both math
and english language arts and they're a
set of topics
for what is suggested to be taught from
kindergarten
through 12th grade in the united states
and the synonyms are posted online you
can just go to
google common core math standards and
you'll see all of the um
standards they were released in 2010
created by a collection of
states and then each state was given the
option to adopt the common core
standards
and as you can see the common christinas
were widely adopted
as of now 41 states and washington dc
guam northern maryland islands and the
u.s virgin islands have chosen to adopt
the math
common core standards so since they're
so widely used already in the united
states
we thought that the common core
standards were a good starting place
for us to start implementing
kindergarten through 12 education in
wolfram alpha
and then something that is distinct
about the common core standards
is their emphasis on mathematical rigor
which from an education standpoint means
that the standards
cover procedural computational fluency
standard edition subtraction algorithms
and so on
but equally they also cover applications
to physical world real world scenarios
and also conceptual understandings of
broad mathematical concepts
and so we can support each of these
aspects and
have them combine to really create that
sense of rigor
in wolframalpha to support the common
core standards
so we'll talk about how all that works
in a little bit but first
jamie's going to talk about the
structure of the standards as they
currently are
involved from alpha
awesome um thanks anne marie so um the
the common core the folks who made the
common core state standards um
actually made it really easy to begin
interacting with them
as a in a computable form in in the the
data form because they are all
available um yeah as xml on the common
core developers page which is linked in
our slides here
um so it was really uh fairly
straightforward for some of the
the more adept uh data folks in wolf
from alpha to pull that in and get us
initially set up with
um standards which is really great um
and and let us
begin uh looking at how can we
how can we think about querying these
standards and how are they all related
to each other
as you can see here in in our graphic um
the standards are broken down in two
primary ways the first being grade level
where we have k through grade eight and
then high school
the the high school is uh grade levels
are all lumped together
to allow high schools the opportunity to
either do an integrated math approach
where you cover
all domains each year from 9th to 12th
grade
or to do a more traditional approach
which would be algebra 1
geometry algebra 2 and so on in high
school
as i've already mentioned there are then
also the content domains
which are a little bit more ragged they
don't span
necessarily all of the grade levels and
even even if they do like geometry um
they're broken up because uh the the
ideas and and the content specifics are
are different um between k-38 and high
school
and then some others um for example
looking at expressions
that the ideas and what what's being
explored in those content standards
changes
so in the green the right in the middle
we can see from k through grade 5
it's operations and algebraic thinking
going up to expressions and equations
and then to high school algebra
um so this is this is great this is an
overview of
sort of what the way the way that the
standards are broken down but when we
get to
looking at specifics of standards um
some people might be familiar with
this uh sort of this period separated
uh long looking standard id
um which i think is one of the things
that can be intimidating about the
common core
it's really not um this is uh just
the systematic way that the common core
uh that you can refer
in the common core you can refer to each
individual standard
um so we have the ccss that's the common
core state standards
math because there's also the english
standards so we differentiate from
english
content because we're talking about
specific
specific content information so
knowing something about the distributive
property or you know some sort of
specifics we're going to be looking at
more of these
um these are differentiated from the
standards of math practice which are a
group of
eight um sort of overarching fleshed out
guidelines for how to do
math that can be applied at any grade
level and really should be integrated
and highlighted
throughout all of the the k through 12
education system
um so we're not talking about those
right now but they are accessible as
well
so we have the content standards and
then the grade level specified by number
then an abbreviation for the content
area
um which are the the little headers in
the
the table that we saw above and um
and then um the final pieces are just
specifying within the standards
uh you know a small grouping so we can
look at an example here for
this standard and um what this gives us
is we get our standard name
we can see that the content area we're
talking about a measurement and data
standard
and the description is measure the
length of an object by selecting and
using appropriate tools such as rulers
yardsticks meter six and measuring tape
so this is more of an application type
standard because we're having to do
something and
making choices about what kind of tools
to use um
but this is an example of a standard
sort of a bite-size
piece of knowledge to to cover
so with that i'm going to hand things
over to emory
to look at some examples great thanks so
with the standards in place we've got
standards and we think about well what
can we from alpha do what results can we
produce that are aligned with the
standards that could
help what a teacher or student who's
working on a specific standard
and so here we've thought about back to
those three elements of mathematical
rigor
different the three the procedural
fluency conceptual understanding and
applications
they happen together and they combine to
make a really rigorous and
thorough math education but certain
standards kind of lend themselves to one
or the other
for example here we've got this standard
id which we can search to find that
it is a number and operations in base 10
that's mbt
standard for fifth grade and the
description is to fluently multiply
multi-digit whole numbers using the
standard algorithm
so this is a pretty straightforward
procedural fluency standard it's asking
us to use an algorithm
to perform multiplication so in wolfram
alpha you can search for a
multiplication problem like 12 times 17
and we have these results and in
particular
when we have uh this step-by-step
solution option we can see that
the standard algorithm is given here at
least for the united states
um and so the wolfram alpha result
supports the procedural fluency dictated
by the standard
okay another example given another
standard
um let's look at the standard this is a
first grade numbers in base 10 standard
and as you can see there's flexibility
in how you can query the standards you
can just give descriptions of what each
part of the id means
and get the standard so another nbt
numbers in base 10
standard but this one you can see is a
little less bite size a little bit more
to it this is now about addition
adding within a hundred and this
standard
asks us to use concrete models or
drawings and strategies
based on place value properties of
operations and so on
so the phrasing of this standard is
really also emphasizing the conceptual
understanding not just following an
algorithm
so we go to wolframalpha we ask it to
add two numbers within 100
like 24 plus 18 and here we get our
result
and again the step-by-step solution is
available for the procedural fluency
and also we have these visualizations
which are the concrete models or
drawings that can represent the concept
of addition
so we have the option of a number line
seeing addition
on a number line and then this
manipulatives illustration in particular
is really great
because it uses that place value
understanding with the tens and the ones
and
even addresses some of the specifics of
the standard when we need to
compose a 10 out of the one units so
here's another example of how
wolfram alpha is aligned to a common
core standard
okay and finally for the last aspect of
mathematical rigor applications
jeremy's going to show us an example in
wolf alpha notebook edition
great so as i'm sharing my screen here
i just wanted to point out uh somebody
asked in the chat
that um some of these queries are not
yet going to be working for you all and
that's totally fine
these are rolling out over the next few
weeks so some of these are going to be
accessible
um so yeah so so the the content
standards should be accessible within
um at most a month it should be sooner
than that most likely
um so uh for those of you who are at the
keynote talk last night you've probably
already seen an example of this wolfram
alpha
notebook edition or a wolfram alpha mode
notebook um
this is a an environment that really
takes the best of both
world from alpha with the natural
language understanding and the ease of
use
and the best of the notebook environment
where you can build up computations over
a series
of where you can build up understanding
and larger
tasks over a series of smaller
computations so
for example here we're going to look at
a more application-based
standard um this is an expressions and
equations
and it says solve real-world and
mathematical problems leading to two
linear equations and two variables
um there's there's more to this just an
example of what this is what we're going
to primarily be looking at
so this is the kind of thing that in
many
in many classrooms would you know be
covered by some sort of word problem
which can be difficult to handle there's
lots of ways to
write word problems and there's um lots
of ways to put in extra information and
complicating factors um which make these
difficult
to sometimes you know parse or interact
with a computational way
but um on our end
uh this is something this is something
that can be really easily and
nicely handled here in the wolfram alpha
notebook edition so our problem
two sisters are in a competition to
raise money for a school trip by selling
candy
latoya already has fifty dollars but
only makes five dollars per sale
jasmine on the other hand has only has
25 dollars
but makes 10 dollars per sale so she's a
she's a better salesperson
when will they have raised the same
amount of money and how much will that
be
this is a classic um classic kind of
intro linear equations um word problem
one of the things that a student would
be asked to do here is to be able to
identify
um what are the what are the key pieces
of information that we can take out of
this to build
a model or that linear equation um
and and the two pieces for each of our
uh sisters here
are the initial value the fifty dollars
in latoya's case
and then the rate five dollars per sale
right
um so taking those pieces of information
we can
we can build it and say that the person
doesn't necessarily student doesn't
necessarily know how to
to write that equation themselves we can
say okay
give us an equation with this slope and
this y-intercept
and wolfram alpha noble addition very
neatly gives us our y equals 5x plus 50
that
standard m x y equals mx plus b equation
similarly for jasmine we can
pull out those same pieces of
information
and then the the key piece of this which
is
how do we go about solving these now
that we have these two equations that's
really great
but we can really easily say solve that
and the one before
to not only
just build up our two equations but also
get our solution which is
after five sales each sister will have
75 dollars
right so answering how many when will
there is the same amount of money and
how much will that be
um additionally just in in case you
wanted to
um just to highlight that we can also
get our our steps
solution here for the procedural fluency
part as well
so with that we're going to hand over to
anri in just a second but
in addition to being able to highlight
these sorts of individual
sample problems in in wolfram alphanopic
edition
the example pages that angry's going to
talk more about are going to be
immediately accessible here
right from within will from alpha
notebook edition so that teachers and
students and parents
can not only see individual standards
but also see our curated
set of examples that go along with all
of them so with that to talk more about
this i'm going to hand back over to ann
marie
thank you okay
so as jeremy mentioned um you can see
examples um organized already for you
um in wolfram alpha notebook edition and
also on the wolfram alpha website
um so we've been curating and compiling
examples that are aligned with each
common core standard
and putting them all in one place so
they're accessible and organized for
whoever wants to use them whether it's
teachers
students a family member helping a
student learning from home this year
if they're working on the common core
math you can go to
uh the mathematics example pages
so on the wolfram alpha website you can
browse examples and see
examples or you could they're actually
already listed here by topic
so in the mathematics example pages
you already have lots of examples so for
example if you needed to know
how to type in an integral to compute it
in mole from alpha there's an example
for that
and what we are building and what should
be available to everyone soon this is a
just an internal version right now is a
section on the mathematics
example pages for common core math
and so this common core math example
page will be
sorted both by grade level
all the grade levels all of the common
core content areas
and you can click here and explore
between grade levels and content areas
examples aligned with specific standards
indicated by their standard ids
so we're hoping this will be a really
neat tool make the common core standards
and wool from alpha more accessible
to a wide variety of people since the
common core standards are so widely used
and as we've been putting together these
example pages with all these lots of
examples align to all sorts of different
standards
we've also seen some opportunities for
improving our alignment
so here's an example of one of the
things that we've done we've noticed
that we can tweak
our features to work better with the
common core standards
so considering this fourth grade
fraction standard
um this standard asks us to compare
two fractions with different numerators
and different denominators
there's some info about conceptual
understanding in there and then
record the results of comparisons with
the inequality symbols
and justify the conclusions with visual
fraction models
there's a lot there uh we start with an
example
of comparing two fractions with
different numerators and different
denominators like
a query which is greater seven eighths
or three-fourths
and the pod the pods that come the
results we see we see the answer and
this is excellent we also have two
concrete visual models both a number
line and these
pie charts also we found opportunities
to improve the results so one thing that
we can do
is add this arithmetic comparison pod to
address that inequality
notation that's mentioned in the
standard so we'll give our answer also
with the inequality notation
to align both a line with the common
core standard and also make it clearer
for
any math student to see the relationship
between the two fractions
and other places that we can
develop the idea of visual models in
particular they're really
used widely to support conceptual
understanding
and there are lots of varieties so pie
charts are great
tape diagrams like these shown here are
also commonly used
so we're exploring different types of
visual models that we can give as
results
to support conceptual understanding and
all of these changes since we're
starting by looking at educational
standards help us to develop
with education in mind so having our
results really be useful
for students who are learning math at
every level
awesome so as we are as we've already
seen
um this is under well underway and is
going to be soon soon to be available to
um
all of our end users both in uh wolfram
alpha on the web and
viable from alpha notebook edition um in
particular there are
some uh some features in wolf alpha
notebook edition which we we're not
going to show now for time reasons but
um you know it allows for more
interactivity and
as we've already seen the the sort of
more dynamic um
dynamic use uh from the users and also
when i say dynamic interactivity like
uh in producing manipulates and not just
a static visual model but something that
somebody might be able to interact with
so
we're excited to be um adding more of
those
and making use of the wolfram function
repository to
um to package up some of the code for
these visualizations and interactive
models as well
for more info you can attend these these
three talks
about wolfram alpha notebook edition um
that are all on friday to learn more
about that and hopefully
um dive into that if you're interested
um
we're also uh looking forward to as ann
marie said
continuing to develop our wall from
alpha coverage of
um of the specifics and the sort of the
specific educationally minded aspects of
the common core standards
in addition to furthering our
integration with the wolfram problem
generator
this is a technology that's been around
for a little while
and itself has some common core
alignment but we'd really love to be
able to tie that further into
wolfram alpha and the results that you
get on wolfram alpha
from those pods and finally um
we're going to be adding hopefully down
the road
more support for other standards both
the common core
english standards uh and other
international and um you know other sets
of standards from around the world which
might
use different algorithms or approach
problems
in in different ways which not only
is it great to be able to cover those
things and and have support but also
i think allows for students to really
see that
math isn't just done one way that it's
done in many ways
around the world and that just the way
like the way that your teacher is
teaching things doesn't have to be the
only way that
you do math um which i think is a great
thing
so um with that we will be wrapping up
here and um again i want to say thank
you so much for
attending our talk today and
particularly thanks to
a number of uh developers on the wolfram
alpha team
who have helped make this project
possible and get us to
where we are here today and at this
point we can take some questions
um either in um
we i see there are a few which i'll we
can address in just a second in the chat
or if you want to raise your hand
uh we can also unmute you i think so
um i see we already addressed the
question about
other countries curricula um thanks for
saying this is nice
and um the next generation science
standards i think that is a great
uh that's a great thing to consider and
is it should be
yeah probably um bumped up our list
since that's pretty widely
adopted throughout the us as well so
thanks for that suggestion
yes um there was a great talk which i
think you can now go see the recording
of this morning
uh on a math artifacts and history of
mathematics project
that was really great we were henry and
i were talking about that before we got
in here
cool well if there are
we can just hang out for a minute if
people have questions um
or uh if not thanks everybody and
um yeah feel free to reach out to anne
marie or i
um we'll we'll put our contact
information in the chat so if anybody
wants to reach out to us
or uh i think there's a meeting
scheduling feature of pathable so you
should be able to
request a meeting with us if you want to
talk more about this as well